so lots to think about then as we carry
on with the press preview
our first look at what is on the front
pages as they come into us here at sky
and tonight we'll see what is making the
headlines with economics correspondent
at the spectator kate andrews
and political editor for the new
statesman stephen bush very good evening
to both of you speak to them in a moment
first of all let's take a look then at
some of those front pages
and unsurprisingly uh they're all
focusing of course on the prime
minister's plans to
gradually lift lockdowns starting with
the times pm
sets out four tests for the end of
lockdown highlighting that new criteria
for easing stay at home to be scrapped
in the telegraph the guardian leads with
school
sports and social contact first as prime
minister plans to lift
lockdown return to the great outdoors
says the mirror on the front of the eye
newspaper
outdoor sport and rule of six in march
and in the daily mail the headlines slow
march to freedom
the express focuses on the government's
cautious attitude with
boris we'll take it one careful step at
a time
and the four steps to freedom is the
headline in the metro
and as i say uh joined tonight by kate
andrews and stephen bush great to see
you both
thanks for being with us this sunday
evening and a huge amount of
anticipation
as to what the prime minister is going
to say tomorrow
and a lot of the detail we've been given
tonight for the front pages let's start
kate shall we with the front of the
daily telegraph stay at home to be
scrapped
as pm unveils route to normality what do
you make of what we've just heard from
sam about how things are going to be
eased
well as sam said it's going to be a very
cautious approach it's going to be a
longer easing of restrictions than it
was in the first national lockdown for a
lot of industries
especially for hospitality uh in in
march you are going to be looking at
more outdoor activity with it being
legal to
uh socialize instead of just exercising
with one person outdoors and then by the
end of march
hopefully the rule of six will be coming
into effect or you'll be able to have
two households meet up even if that
exceeds
uh the rule of six um but it's going to
be a tough time for the hospitality
industry which is being told that
they're months away from being able to
reopen and i actually think
the key thing on the front of the
telegraph isn't simply the timeline
but the fact that social distancing is
thought to be in place for many many
months
now a lot of the industry has said look
we're not enjoying being shut down but
what's really important is that when
we're allowed to come back we can do so
with a bang for a lot of these
industries
it's going to be very difficult to
operate at say 50 or even 75
capacity and turn a profit so the fact
that social distancing
will remain for the foreseeable future
even with vaccines is going to be a
really tough pill for a lot of the
hospitality industry to swallow
yeah it really is uh stephen uh clearly
the government being incredibly
cautious not wanting to repeat any
mistakes that were made
in the previous lockdowns yes
i think this plan does show that the
government has learned from some of the
mistakes it made particularly
over the summer and into the early
winter which is one problem we had is
because we opened everything at once we
weren't able when
uh cases started to rise to be able to
work out what we could keep open we had
we were forced essentially to go
right let's just close everything in a
bit of a panic so i think it's a very
sensible approach for that reason
yeah and uh just staying with you
stephen we're hearing about these four
tests and actually there is positive
news on all four
of the prime minister's tests at the
moment just having a look at the front
of the
metro they outline them in a bit more
detail the four steps
to freedom um clearly the first step
is going to be the reopening of schools
and it sounds as if there isn't going to
be a staggered approach
it's going to be all kids back at the
same time
yeah so that that does contain a
slightly bigger risk in terms of the r8
but of course we do have
a very successful vaccine rollout
program and of course we do also know
that the
cost to children of not being at school
is pretty high
and actually this is an important thing
as you say on all four of these metrics
that
all of the lights are at the moment
flashing green with the really important
proviso
the only country with a more advanced
vaccine rollout than we
we have israel has very good news but
they have good news about the pfizer
vaccine
the thing we don't know yet is how
effective the oxford vaccine is
at preventing transmission we know it's
important protecting
you from hospitalization and death what
we don't know is whether or not it's
good at preventing you giving it to
someone who doesn't have the vaccine
yeah um kate uh the one thing we're all
desperate to do of course is socialize
again
meet up with family and friends and
clearly that is
going to happen now uh albeit in a very
slow and measured way how do you think
this is going to go down with
the public because the polls have all
suggested that
they don't want anything to happen too
fast
yeah what we've seen throughout the past
year is that the public have been
very forgiving of the government very
understanding when we've had to crack
down on these restrictions
and also broadly speaking very compliant
although there have been some questions
around
the most important roles like staying at
home when you have symptoms but when it
comes to many of the other
rules we have seen that people are
broadly quite happy to do it
i do wonder as the vaccine program if it
does continue to be a success no reason
to think it won't be in fact the
spectators vaccine projectors suggest
that we could be
hitting the top nine priority groups
even before
the end of march whether or not people
will still feel the same
ethical responsibility that is once the
risk of potentially harming the elderly
your grandparents even your parents
starts to fade
whether or not you will get more
pressure from the public not just say
backbencher conservative mps to lift
some of these
restrictions because as i said before
this is actually a slower process of
opening up
than it was last year when we didn't
have any working vaccines
and i think if we look to those four
tests it's actually important to break
them down
as steven says we're flashing green on
all four but two of them
and one that is linked to infection
rates that they wouldn't put any risk uh
on the national health service and the
other about a no need
new change in variant these are rules
that you could see the government
and you've got enough leeway there
enough flexibility
that you wouldn't even necessarily have
to make the case in the data to say we
want to slow down even more
and i think that's when the prime
minister might starting might start
getting even more pushback from those in
his own party and potentially the public
as people are really keen and eager to
have a summer that feels a lot more
normal than last summer
when we didn't have any of these
vaccines yeah let's talk about the
summer uh front page of the daily mirror
return to the great outdoors they talk
about people meeting in the park for
a drink or a cup of tea whatever it
might be sport resuming march the 29th
but they also make the point that
holidays
in britain and beer gardens will be
allowed in april but there's no
uh talk about international travel and
of course a lot of people
wanting to book a summer holiday uh the
travel industry absolutely on its knees
saying that uh travel should be brought
back by may
given how well vaccination is going uh
stephen do you think we'll hear anything
about that tomorrow from the from the
prime minister
i doubt it and i mean to be honest i
don't really think that hospitality has
got a particularly reasonable case here
right
the pace of vaccination in other
countries is not really something that
the government can control
they can help in countries where the
pace of vaccines is slowed because
countries don't have sufficient means to
procure as many vaccines as they have
which is something we're doing through
kovacs and to the global vaccines
initiative
but through countries which are doing it
slower for other other reasons where
it's not simply a matter of giving them
money or giving them vaccine supplies
ultimately that is a pretty hard
constraint on the ability
of people to go on holidays further
afield if they so desire
yeah where do you stand on this kate
because if uh
vaccine passports in some form are
brought in and
uh the majority of adults have had the
jab by the summer
um can it be a situation where the
government can say well look you still
can't go away
well stephen makes a very important
point that a lot of international travel
comes down to what's happening in
external countries not simply
what's happening at home but you've
already had indication from very popular
destination points like greece that they
plan to open tourism this summer almost
regardless of their vaccine status
i think it's going to be very difficult
for the british government which has
vaccinated its population for anybody
who wants to take the job
to say well you are being invited
elsewhere but we're not going to allow
you to go
now there have been there has been some
talk today that foreign holidays might
be on the cards for later in the summer
but again you're actually looking at
potentially a more restrictive summer on
the domestic and international front
um certainly towards the beginning of
the summer than you were
last year and that's something that the
government is going to have to to square
because of vaccines
perhaps silver bullet is the wrong term
but if they are the game changer and all
of the data so far
would suggest they are and hopefully in
the next few weeks we're going to get
even more data as steven pointed to
about the real world effect
on transmission when it comes to the
oxford vaccine um well then that really
should be the ticket that we need to
start going back to normal
both domestically and abroad because the
threat in the uk will hopefully subside
yeah and stephen just a quick final
thought from you front page of the daily
mail
slow march to freedom i mean they do
talk in
on their front page about the agony
going on for shops pubs
hair salons as well kate's already
mentioned this but of course there are
so many
businesses on there and walks of life
that are still going to struggle even
despite
um the prime minister announcing an
easing of some restrictions tomorrow
yeah they're going to have real problems
and they're going to need more subsidy
at the moment the subsidy regime is for
wages and rent two very important costs
but they
assumed the idea that people would be
able to still have a big christmas a
profitable christmas
that hasn't happened for most of these
businesses so they are almost certainly
almost
all going to need a further injection of
government supply
if this timetable is going to be kept to
without having a huge
cost in terms of unemployment and
bankruptcies yeah of course okay uh
stephen kate thank you
for the moment don't go away coming up
the end of lockdown is looming
we look at plans for schools sports and
socialising
that's coming up after the break
hello again part two of the press
preview kate and steven's still with me
let's look at the front page of the
guardian kate
matt hancock uh in the news uh for
uh different reasons friend of hancock
in inquiry over
covid work tell us about this the
guardian is reporting that the uk
medicines agency
is investigating a company named hinpak
for
possible breaches in hygiene and safety
standards now the reason this is getting
front page attention
is because the company is owned by a
former neighbor of matt hancock who was
given a very lucrative government
contract to create vials
for the nhs uh last year during the
pandemic despite the company not
previously
having experience in in making this um
in this particular thing
now uh it should be said that alex born
the company chief says that he's not
aware of this investigation
and it appears according to the
guardians reporting that it's just
starting there are no findings yet
innocent till proven guilty all the rest
uh certainly apply but i suppose it's an
important reminder
uh that many of the normal proceedings
were suspended last year
a competitive bid to get a very
lucrative government contract basically
went out the window for many companies
because of the emergency laws but um
it's always better when these things can
be transparent especially
when it comes to taxpayer money yeah of
course all allegations uh
so far as you say the government's
saying uh constantly that it was an
emergency
situation they were under huge pressure
of course to deliver
let's move on to the front of the daily
telegraph stephen and
it's all talk about rope everyone's got
a road map haven't they at the moment uh
including it would seem
uh donald trump he's been selling out
his road map to
2024. yes he's speaking at uh cpac which
is
uh the kind of it's sort of the biggest
bash in the republican party
calendar and he's expected to stand up
and confirm we're kind of all guest
which is
he's running again obviously because he
lost re-election he's not term limited
he can run for a second time
i think it does show the blunder and a
lot of republican politicians
made in choosing to defend donald trump
rather than
using the opportunity because it would
be the right thing to do morally because
it would be in the correct thing to do
for their own political
uh aspirations and i think many of those
senators who hoped and they would be
able to become the presidential
candidate
are probably going to realize very
quickly that as long as donald trump is
on the political stage
that ain't going to happen he's still
very popular among the republican rank
and file
even though of course he's very divisive
in the country as a whole yeah i mean
that's right
kade isn't it you know donald trump
still has many many millions of
supporters
he did he got the second largest share
of votes for a presidential candidate in
history the first of course
was joe biden which is why he won the
election i think stephen's completely
right a lot of republicans
uh will find that they made a huge
mistake thinking that they would be the
candidate in 2024
by trying to be donald trump light or
trying to defend the president and his
policies and now may be realizing
actually
president trump will fill those shoes
and it's the anti-trump lot those that
acknowledge the huge mistakes that he
made especially on his way out the door
that may actually be competitive but
it's also a reminder of the problem of a
of an electoral system
where you don't have an opposition
leader you don't have a leader for the
party that didn't win
it means that there is this void and
donald trump is such a big presence it's
no surprise he's going to try
uh to fill it and that means an uphill
battle for the republicans who want to
move on from the trump era and
reestablish the party
okay and uh just finally stephen uh back
here
uh we're on the eve of uh a huge day
tomorrow
uh what sort of tone would you like the
prime minister to set
as he speaks in parliament and then
speaks to the nation at seven o'clock
um i would quite like him to strike as
lucid and as accessible a tone as
possible as
much as i enjoy hearing from uh school
friends people i've worked from in the
past going uh hey mate can you explain
exactly what the prime minister's just
said
i don't think it's a very good um system
a lot of people don't uh have a school
friend who who works for the national
magazine
and i think a little bit more clarity in
his communication would be wonderful
okay and a very quick thought from you
kate and it's just in a couple of
sentences
uh we need some optimism i think the
prime minister has over corrected
uh for being too optimistic in the past
it's been too pessimistic the past few
months and i'd like to see a return to
uh
not just normality but the prime
minister saying that we can get there
and hopefully
soon